[Musique]
on a voulu vous rendre hommage comme
vous faites particulièrement bien le
portugais on a demandé aux chroniqueurs
s'ils savaient faire des accents donc un
tour de rôle ils vont et vous allez
noter vous avez une ardoise vous mettez
une vraie notre une alarme ou voulant
mettre une autre chacun un accent que je
vais tirer au sort qu'ils n'ont rien
préparé puisqu'ils ne savent pas
l'accent qui va sommer simard accent
français julien alors quand vous dites
on va bien se marrer
mettez vous en doutez il va se passer
quelque chose c'est sûr je suis pas sûr
qu'ils ont déjà oui j'avais pas ou à la
boule faut prévenir vstv un brin des
moeurs qui vont prendre toute la
séquence
ah oui ça s'apprend pas comme norauto
bride l'accent américain pour que génial
ras le bol à ok c'est ça que quand même
non alors je vais chez ma blague on
américain c'est ce à quoi on allait
mézil
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup
oh
puis 10
au niveau américain non parce que
reconnaissons que le jeu n'était pas
assez de force ont tous été sur sa
puissante avec on y va alors le chemin
qu'il fallait parler l'album pourquoi
les femmes ne doivent plus se marier
pourquoi pourquoi les femmes ne veulent
plus se marier
quelque chose de lui comme apple au bout
de saison ça c'est les années
d'expérience donc pourquoi les femmes ne
veulent pas se marier elle préfère avoir
du jambon dans le frigo
plutôt qu'un gros porc dans le salon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je viens à l'instant de comprendre la
feuille du jeu c'est d'avoir demandé aux
chroniqueurs d'essayer d'être drôle en
fait il suffit de faire un accent est
une part l'accent américain je bats vu
que mon frigo et fait très froid dans le
frigo et ça va péter rice a d'ailleurs
valu matin un joli 100 m je rappelle que
c'est notez sur vos
[Applaudissements]
ça tombe bien parce qu'un film qui fait
l'actu et carys habitants l'accent room
c'est parti alors s'il vous plaît
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
souple et qu'est ce qu'ils veulent au
garage et qui en coule et ben c'est une
femme portugaise qu'est-ce-qui qu'elle
se marie à se garer roucoule joue cool
et ceux de masques sont tombés sur le
portugais voyez on monte en gamme déjà
les roumains la amaigri au portugal en
fait directement vous pouvez tenait
james s'il vous plaît guillaume hoarau
il anime tant que soldat c'est ce soir
non non c'est devant un épisode c'est
fini la saison
les prochaines s'cusez moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais quand c'est fini mais je n'avais
rites et avec patrick sabatier ça passe
toujours
on y va pour l'attaqué manquée de moi et
me dit lopez et vous allez vous taper un
petit accent créole est ce que des gens
dans la salle allez-y c'est bon c'est
bon
non mais franchement je sais pas ou non
à les emballer un vraiment ça fond qui
va à la chasse à un couple qui se
dispute et au cours de la dispute
l'homme
ils haussent la voix et idy une tension
élections parce que là ça devient
incohérent comprend non seulement
reconnais plus c'est nul placé d'où il
dit à sa doudou et vous connaissez une
histoire en créole monsieur non bon et
bien voulu métal 0 merci enfin est-ce
que vous puissiez vous et moi oui emilie
est ce que vous pourriez au moins nous
donner l'histoire en france et compte
qu'on la connaisse un coût que se
disputent et la femme dit à son mari et
c'est bon tu vas changer de ton là et le
mari répond maintenant que je suis très
bien avec toi
bien
[Applaudissements]
le match
c'est dommage parce que cette blague
avait un potentiel cap est exploité vous
pouvez auprès de la direction de la
chaîne surtout nous allons donner la
parole à ces démarrera aux spécialistes
de télé 7 jours qui va nous faire une
blague et bas l'action peut sauver la
blague par contre attention
qu'est-ce qui est transparent et quillan
messieurs
si vous avez la chance un jour de
croiser un portugais qui fait qu est ce
qui est le sport au nail effet pu faire
des fois pour trouver qui parle comme ça
vous pouvez vous faire les à huy en
ordre et ne trouve pas les airs rétro
c'est bien essayé le bas-côté n'importe
quoi l'on comprend rien mais oui alors
les hémicycles
qu'est ce qui est étrange par
l'américain coty le portugais parti
vivre à l'avenir en français il va
devenir bien plus bien de moi en caisse
qui est transparent qui traverse les
champs un fantôme un troupeau de vitres
super alors voyez c'est le prends
doublement mal
vous avez massacré l'accent est en plus
venir me raconter une histoire de vitres
à moi je trouve ça
un grand classique lalime passer par la
fenêtre
peut-être oui oui merci thierry l'accent
belge à baho
on va essayer c'est un petit garçon qui
rentre chez lui qui dit à son frère
ça y est je sais comment on fait les
enfants à la loupe des vols d'air bon
oui ben le papa il met une graine dans
la maman verberie après et a pris pour
très loin avec la mi temps
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non parce que je suis ce qui va se
passer
nos amis belges où on croit qu'on a
choisi sept blocs pour se moquer d'eux
toujours sorti 13 oui est ce que vous
aimeriez si je pouvais vous faire
plaisir
tout me va tout va et bien c'est
l'italien qui vient de sortir
fabien choné que tout le monde se de vie
se passe quelque chose de très important
c'est un sort clé de l'histoire de la
télévision
brault fait dans une marque à 2 oui au
nord de l'italie c'est comme ça qu'on
dit nabil et chine italie
mais comment l'italien mais dans une
myriade o'connor un peu mieux avec les
masses ne nous avaient pas l'accent sas
yona qui fait quoi et l'autre qui lui
zhimin c'est exactement ce que j'allais
dire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était un italien qui nous a raconté
cette blague m nous allons enchaîner
avec isabelle morini-bosc une bonne
nouvelle pour les accents les plus beaux
fous là je vais vous dire où on joue on
se procure même plus de savoir si ça
ressorte l'accent marseillais s'il vous
plaît l'ex amant ben non quand je ne
tiens pas là au fait le moine est un peu
cher et moins chère alors mon histoire
c'est une histoire très simple c'est un
jeu comme monsieur vient de gagner 10
millions j'ai déjà raconté mais je
l'aimé bien c'est un monsieur qui veut
gagner des millions d'euros et alors il
ouvre sa fenêtre
encore une histoire de fenêtres et dit
il faut sa femme dans la rue et me dit
j'ai rien à gagner des millions d'euros
à lui dit quoi et on a gagné des
millions d'euros ma chère me vire je
vais te la raconter
alors elle vient et paf le bus écrasés
hélas le mari dit au nom de dieu quand
c'est une bonne journée c'est une bonne
javaux sa bien aimée
[Applaudissements]
jalil ya longtemps que je vous ai
demandé de ne plus noter parce que mal à
l'aise par rapport aux siens c'est là la
tension pour l'instant c'est là mais
elle a su trouver l'accessoire le peu
cher fait la différence hier qu'après
c'était du belge était tous un peu cher
pour qu'on vous allez vous refaire
l'italien vous plusieurs fois dans
l'émission parce que là je reviens pas
d'accent français et bien ça tombe bien
parce que je ne sais faire que l'accent
français
c'est l'action marocain aucun cas précis
je sais pas tenter eux vivement lot
marie ah oui pourquoi ils ont pas d'un
simple marocain elle n'est pas tombée
cette envie d'elle elle sait se sortir
de toutes les situations
elle s'est dit je vais tourner sans au
piège et bien julien vous ne m'aurez pas
car les marocains n'ont pas d'accès sans
fil auxonne rockeur un petit peu comme
une action avec quelqu'un peut m'aider
pour commencer à les jaloux les derbys
pour tu meurs mal danger voilà pourquoi
les les galas il s'assoit toujours les
jambes écartées pour que leur cerveau
respire alors si j'ai bien compris quand
on veut parler marseillais ont fait
n'importe quoi il suffit de dire peu
cher quand on veut faire maroc et
suffire à mal tous les quatre mois il
est grand temps que ça se termine avec
vous damier gagner s'il vous plaît
essayez de relever le niveau ph du riez
ouais je suis le héros ça va aller vous
allez vous prendre un petit accent
allemand
l'entravé les faire ça guten morgen
quelle est la femme la plus intelligente
vente
la blonde la brune et la rousse et bien
c'est la route parce que c'est un
dictionnaire
merci
[Applaudissements]
mais
il ya quand même pas dire quand on juge
quand la blague est drôle c'est mieux
comme ça on s'en aperçoit tout de suite
voilà il avait l'accent alors qu'il a
gagné je pense qu'on est tous d'accord
pour dire que c'est isabelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]